[Music]
three
two one action hey guys welcome back to
off the record where we talk about
whatever we want
and today we have big boy he was
cracking
what's up you're a big boy i thought it
was big mood okay so
we've just met this morning right and i
accidentally was like
hi nice to meet you big big mood in the
house yeah
oops i'm that big mood that big vibe you
know
that's true that's true yeah wait so how
do you guys know each other
because bart uh brought him up over here
so um i met him in the pen
and he was like these are cell mates i
need someone i thought i met you at that
ramen house no
wasn't it that uh tofu ramen house yeah
it was in the corner of
cell block d where we made the instant
noodles that's what you call it
the folsom wing this folsom wing okay i
met big boy through fitness
and i always thought it was really
inspiring because you know he's been
locked up but then he came out and he
has like this big fitness
uh empire like he had a gym supplements
clothing and he's just killing it
what's it called strength cartel street
strength right now oh that's tight
sc that's before dishonor right here i'm
rocking
strength cartel right now
he's putting it down for the chicanos i
thought was really really cool so i
wanted to
bring him on and share a story and maybe
you can like talk a little bit about it
because i know most people
they don't come out of jail and become
like the next
ceo of no they go back to jail they
usually go right
role violations parole violations you
know like how did that even start how
did you get into fitness how did you go
i'm gonna build like a
fitness company empire oh man i mean it
was
pretty much i don't want to say it was
easy but just kind of fell into it been
working out for sports for years
[Music]
since i was maybe like 13 years old been
kind of banging weights playing sports
and uh
so that came easy the working out
obviously got busted
came out was into football played a
couple years at a
college football and what position i
played
linebacker d-line full-back pretty much
everything
the end if you follow instagram you're
like this [ __ ] can move
fast it's 300 pounds fast i like to be
athletic
look at him bar put me on your instagram
oh yeah and
and and i was like yo this guy can skate
man
i'm opposing i'm opposing no i mean like
you're hitting rails and [ __ ] and i was
like
oh damn dude and it's funny because you
know your size right and you play onto
that and you're like 300 pound skater
oh yeah i got it and i'm like yo the
board is not breaking it's pretty crazy
i thought i thought skateboards had a
weight capacity but i guess not
yeah so what is it uh they say
skateboards have seven ply
and they're like well uh average
skater's about 150
so like you need like a 14 ply oh [ __ ] i
already broke a couple boards
i broke a couple boards i blew out like
the bushings
you know what that is in the trucks yeah
blew those out like in 20 minutes so
we've been like trouble yeah i'm not
joking just the first thing bam yeah
but uh blew out the side you know oh
[ __ ] yeah you're using specialty skates
now or you're just breaking them as you
go
um no we're trying to figure it out
we're trying to figure it out but uh
just trial and error right now because
you know they've never seen a dude over
three bills on a board
so i gotta say pretty crazy you have a
right to drink monster energy drinks by
the way
i have no [ __ ] right yeah at all
like you you should be like on a [ __ ]
skateboard drinking this [ __ ] that makes
sense
because he loves monsters yeah yeah but
i'm sitting on a computer typing and i'm
like
everywhere shout out shout out to
monster you know
he's actually a sponsor too is that
right oh cool
there we go first power lifter i got it
for power lifting first power lifter is
sponsored by monster
yeah dude if they ever have power
jerking my buddy here
oh yeah he's the man he's absolutely
he'll be there good to know good to know
good to know i'll make sure i won't uh
shake his hand you know
there you go we got corona anyway so the
elbow okay yeah
throw the ball been touching oh no do
people ever ever ask you are you
are you a big boy uh uh no they asked me
if i
work out and i say no i was born
that's it i mean it's a rhetorical
question i would think you work out no
huh
where did you grow up um so la
originally but i moved to orange county
with the fam san clemente is where i'm
from
okay yep but originally everyone's from
this area
la like um pasadena eagle rock highland
park
glendale all this area yeah were you
born
a cholo born a cholo were you a baby and
you came out
and put long socks yeah yeah i mean
i kind of followed in suit of my bro and
that's like kind of like what he was so
you kind of look up to you know what i
mean yeah
but uh we we like sports and um
and skating we pretty much played it all
but of course that was a lifestyle
especially l.a
yeah right you know yeah yeah you can't
get away from it
you know and uh so yeah it's just kind
of in you
you know your family whatever so so was
it weird then
to to come out and start making content
online you know like because you know
for sure
like we didn't like and we never went to
jail but we did grow up in san diego i
got lucky
and it's like htv yeah it's like uh
it was just like a giant hood right so
when we first started coming out
we thought like only we could make
content and everyone else
is like like a wussy yeah like you know
i had that mindset
for sure i mean before i even started my
brand and things like that like
i had maybe like facebook and i would
never post on facebook i wouldn't want
to do videos or pictures i was just
there to have it did you have pictures
with the black bars on your eyes
i just literally didn't post nothing i
wouldn't even i thought it was like you
said fruity
yeah yeah that's fruity right it starts
with the empty
yeah when we when we started doing
youtube and doing stupid stuff and we
started getting fans
it changed i think i started trusting
people more because
um like every time you see uh uh guys
that look like they bang right and then
they stare at you you know they're gonna
probably hit you up right
yeah yeah and then so we would get
paranoid like oh [ __ ] man that table
right there when we when we get up
they're gonna [ __ ] say something
and then they'll be like hey uh can we
get a picture
no 100 i i was just going to say it's
the same exact thing with me
before it's like this was this was
trying to dog me like what's up with
this for
late this fall like what are you looking
at you know like how you were thinking
that before like
i seen you on youtube so you're
inspiring if you buy sir
yeah yeah bicep curls yup all day and
it's funny when
they look pretty hard too but then they
get all giggly and [ __ ]
yeah yeah no it's dope dog your mindset
has to change and
you have to evolve and you know reinvent
yourself
all that kind of stuff so you know i'm
surprised anyone would dog you
to begin with because you look like you
could punt them down a football field
and
feel about what it is they always want
to test the biggest dude that's just
you know you got a target the little
dude wants to test the big dude in
that's so true
you know what it's all yeah but it's all
good you're not that big dude you're not
that big
nah i'm small i'm small it's an illusion
there's no why though cause
the the the little guy would always win
even if they lose
because if if i stepped up twice because
at least they tried we fought and i got
my ass
handed to you yeah it's like duh
of course he's gonna beat me but i'm
crazier because i stepped up to him
yep and then it's like the little guy
always wins even if he loses
that's like me we're skating right now
you know i'm big if i suck it's all good
i'm big it's good
you know it's the opposite that's tight
dan so you keep busy then you have
an empire to run you're skateboarding
you're working out
what else are you into well what are all
the parts of your empire you got like
clothing supplements yeah we got
you know like bart said clothing
supplements
um we know we do some online training
and meals
uh we got the youtube and then the
sponsorships and then um
yeah it's all in san clemente uh
pretty much all oc all orange county
yeah
so which with each brand like each piece
of uh clothing that you have
if i buy each one how many pounds can i
gain with each instantly
you put on a straight cartel shirt 10
pounds every day
wow yeah 10 pounds that's so much better
than bob robert david why not
you lose weight oh there you're weak
this whole time you'll get techno music
whatever you know you go to my you get
the gangster rap you know
everyone is a little bit techno yeah
that's true that's true
at barbell you get tupac but with bart
and
pink shorts dancing if i come in music
dude i love how barbell is dominate
humbly yeah so like mike tyson's
supposed to be like
i won no i'm not that good
like kobe bryant game winning point and
then shhh
so when michael jordan sinks the jump
shot to win
the the third title he's supposed to
just not not jump in the air like that
he's just supposed to go like
he's not uh he wouldn't be our most
ideal athlete now that would be a great
iconic photo michael jordan going
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah nah he
would be our idea kobe bryant would be
okay i see sink the shot
you turn michael down for kobe i see yes
it's time for today's sponsor
today's video is brought to you by hello
tushy
thank you so they sent me a package they
hooked me up
and um now i got a clean ass thank you
very much
and also you know extremely buff dudes
like me
we have a difficult time reaching around
and [ __ ] wiping our ass
so using hello tushy helps
me out and helps all of the super buff
guys like me out
in the world some other facts that you
may not know hello tushie does cut
toilet paper used by 80 percent
so it pays for itself simply by how much
toilet paper it saves you
and because with hello touch you don't
have to wipe at all hello too she is
your new hands-free
butt buddy and it sprays and it's super
clean and every hello tissue bode
attachment comes with
a 60 day risk-free happy butt guarantee
and a 12
month warranty so there's no risk to try
it
make sure you go to hellotissue.com to
get 15 off hello tushy but days
plus free shipping right now at
hellotoshi.com
off the record that's off the record
it's the code to use
this is hello to she's best offer so
make sure your
holidays i like that a little happier
and you're brown
friday a little cleaner by going to
hellotissue.com
off the record for 15 off bidets and
free shipping
uh genuine question a lot of people come
out of prison right right
this everything stacked against them
they now have a record like they're like
i'm [ __ ]
how do you get out of that mindset and
go like i'm actually gonna try to do
something different
that's a good question um i guess before
i got out of prison i had already had a
mindset of that i wanted to do good i
didn't come out with like
go back to my old ways or get really
down on myself i kind of had a mission
i always played football too in high
school that was my thing
and um i wanted to go back and play
football you know that
that was my goal that was the only thing
i really knew you know what i mean so
uh i i was lucky that i had that and i
could
you know come out and play so uh yeah
that that was my mindset but
the biggest thing is just to keep
pushing
you know it's not always going to be
easy i'm sure every single one of us
went through some kind of like trials in
our life but
you guys keep our head up and keep going
you know can't keep ganking down on
ourselves so when you have homies that
go back
in jail do you laugh at them
not even dog i feel bad this guy's a
dick
this guy's a true dick you drive by and
uh hey what's up you see this guy
you know give him uh give him a you know
something
when you see this guy you know yeah
exactly check
out to this fool but nah i feel bad
honestly man because that's not the way
of life you know yeah yeah yeah yeah
freedom's ain't nothing to be freedom
man
nothing you know so i love i love being
out here free
doing what i want living life and doing
it in a positive way now so i wouldn't
change
change it for nothing you know what are
some things that you feel like after you
came out you feel like
uh maybe you or anyone else takes for
granted like the freedom that we have
first can literally be anything man just
getting up getting food out of your
fridge you know going outside
taking a fresh breath of air i mean when
i paroled
and uh you know almost did four years so
when i paroled not like the long time
but it was a good time to
take away your your youth that went in
when i was 19 years old so
i took pretty much my good youth years
away and uh
man when you pro you're just so life is
the best all you could literally i
remember
like i could just walk down the street
and look around and i'm happy
you know wow yeah like you're the most
happy and content with nothing
just you got some shoes on you got your
free freedom and
you're just taking in the fresh air and
that [ __ ] feels good
and i tell myself all the time like damn
i want to get back to that because now
you want to go back and jump no just get
back to that
that way of thinking you know that
mindset that i appreciate yeah that
appreciation
everyone should go to jail for a little
bit right
if you're depressed yeah if you're
depressed just go to jail then get out
yeah there you go that's like right now
with the whole like pandemic and us
obviously it's not comparable to prison
it's like we're in prison that's what
ellen said
it's not the same obviously but like you
know similarly in a sense where we don't
have
the regular everyday normal life that we
had
pre-pandemic like does do you feel like
um it kind of takes you back a little
bit to
like hell no no no like slightly like
having that feeling of like for example
getting out of your house and doing your
things that you're doing on day to day
like it's like
a tiny bit of that freedom feeling again
where it's like
some of the freedoms are cut off from
before yeah no hell no i'm free man i'm
out here i do what i want
yeah yeah yeah yeah so he could even be
friends with asians
yeah exactly the others it takes time it
does take time
because if we were all in jail we can't
be friends oh yeah you're programming on
the other side homie i know we gotta
the other side of the day room that's
why you're over there we gotta be
pretend friends
that's true
damn so you guys don't even get like the
yard area at the same time
people gotta go at different times or
it's like [ __ ] of course man everyone
just has their section you know
yeah so they have their areas exactly do
you feel like
you were able to build your empire
because you had that appreciation
leaving jail
like do you feel like if you didn't go
to jail you wouldn't have that like no
i don't i don't believe that but um
i believe that our past creates our
character
you know and we can never be ashamed of
that like a lot of people like oh you
uh what is it called a glorified jail
like no i don't but i'm not
um ashamed of my past it's made me who i
am right
whatever your past whatever you went
through is made bart or you you know
everybody has
you know their history and that's how
they build their character
you live this great life your whole life
you're not gonna probably have much
character you're not gonna be able to
handle hard situations like the pandemic
whatever but
those situations build you for what's
going on in your life now you know so
hell no man i nah
you know i'm happy i'm not happy but you
know i'm thankful for where i'm at and
i'm thankful for where god has me in
this position right now so do you think
the department of corrections actually
like corrects
behavior and helps helps no not at all
yeah before it was just cdc you know
california department of corrections
they added the r rehabilitation no uh-uh
just cage you up like animal you know
but at least it's all privately owned i
think that's
there's privately owned prisons for sure
and those are the uh
the lower levels of ccfs uh things like
that
those are like the level one yards and
those are privately owned but the other
ones are mostly all state
the high security like i will say level
three and up three four you know so and
all the shoe programs
go to state and and and all the more
like temporary ones go to
there's there's state-owned prisons that
are like one yards for sure
most most like uh let's say you're gonna
go to pelican bay right yeah
they have a one yard and a four yard
because if they only have
dudes on the four yard all these killers
they can't go in the kitchen and cook
they can't wash your clothes oh so they
gotta have the one yarders there that
have like through the charcoal pretty
much yeah doc
to work you got to have work i would
hate to be there i know
have you ever seen the dudes that are
like like this with the mask on the
humans and [ __ ]
they jingle into the room yeah and
they're like a celebrity and everyone's
like
nah i've heard stories like uh homies
that have been busted with uh
um what is it like charles manson and
things like that yeah
i heard he was at um what prison was
he at uh it's up north though
he was up there but uh yeah that bring
him in on a dolly next to him
and things like that like they would did
they bring him in on a dolly like in the
movie
they put them in a dolly and then
methodical and like he could speak to
anyone they tell the guards like
don't speak to him don't conversate
nothing not even like
how's your day manipulate you like oh
yeah like that like
they would tell them in i guess he would
you know the vents right any vent and
you're in small cells you could talk to
the vans and
they would say he'd talk to the vents
and the homies whatever whatever race
you are
don't listen to this dude like he'd
speak in the vents and you'd hear him
crazy stuff yeah yeah yeah like the
devil himself yeah so they told me some
crazy stuff
that homies were uh busted with them and
stuff like that he's still alive
corcoran corcoran shooting that's what
he was and i think he died oh
he finally died finally yeah he's in the
corcoran shoe so uh
yeah crazy man crazy but yeah i haven't
man i haven't so
did you ever go into solitary uh
solitary
or the shoe oh no not the shoe but the
hole and that's not solitary i don't
know what's that's between the shoe and
the
segregated housing unit secure housing
unit that's just um where you're gonna
do
a longer period of time in the hole i
watched half a season of prison break so
that's why you know
okay the hole is usually like i'm not
getting technical someone's probably
gonna tell me but
i will say the whole is like probably
like a year and under and the shoe is
gonna be
um longer you know of just no daylight
like that
yeah dog like solitary is less than a
year
or is solitary the whole
so like solitaire when you go to the
hole
you have to sign paperwork if you want
another selly to come in
like if you're in a cell right you
automatically get a selly
yeah but if you're in the hole it's like
a liability so you have to basically
sign your life away like saying hey bart
can come in to sell with me okay let me
sign this away because
once you're in the cell i don't know if
we got beef and what's gonna happen
so in the hole you sign your life away
and then you have a whole different set
of rules you know
but um yeah so the hole in the shoe are
very similar i never been to the shoe so
i don't want to really speak on that but
my boy wix he spent like seven years in
the shoe
and uh man yeah it's crazy man he could
tell you some crazy stories
but uh when you go to the shoe is it
like to see any light like so
you get yard right that's where they get
the you heard exhibit like 23 hour lock
down you get one
hour out a day so you hit the yard which
is not a yard it's probably like
maybe this size smaller and you only get
a little vent
that has light and that's the only light
you see is just that little bit of
sunlight
seven years straight no life seven years
straight
and you get an hour of this much life
yeah
yeah so yeah he's told me some crazy
stories
that's what i'm saying that's some
there's some animals it's correction
he's getting corrections
no rehabilitating rehabilitation sit in
a room all day like a hamster
yeah well your mind's just working and
plotting 24
7. yep wow yeah
kind of like create monks but it's like
working the opposite how do you bypass
time jack off oh just follow right
we're gonna go numb all the time like go
jack off and then like
don't overhear a conversation in the
middle of it they'll be like actually
and then they'll butt in and stop
jacking off what the hell
[Laughter]
is this flat you're gonna be saying that
a lot today okay
he's into that he's into that he's into
that i think bart bart told me he had a
few fifi's at his house
oh phoebe's are awesome yeah he's had a
few fifi so
he put me on that [ __ ] fleshlight
dude
i sell flashlights online what's a fifi
it's a fifi bag it's like a pocket [ __ ]
that you make
yeah homemade pocket [ __ ] in jail out
of a glove
you should do a youtube tutorial on that
[ __ ] because i saw this video of this
dude making spread
on youtube oh it might have been one of
them i like how he's asking he's like
do a youtube tutorial on that so i can
watch it
we'll do that off camera for you buddy
you'll be hooked
you